وفي تجاذبات الملف النووي الايراني وصل
مفتشون من الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
الى طهران للتاكد من نسبه التخصيب في
منشات النوويه هناك الزياره تاتي بعد
تقرير لوكاله بلومبر قبل ايام اثار
المخاوف حول طموحات ايران النوويه بعد
العثور على جزيئات يورانيوم مخصبه لنسبه
وصلت الى
84% وهي نسبه قريبه من المستوى المطلوب
لانتاج اسلحه ذريه شددت الوكاله الامريكيه
على ان المفتشين عليهم تحديد ما اذا كانت
ايران انتجت هذه المواد عمدا او ما اذا
كانت تركيز ناتجا عن حادث غير مقصود اثناء
تقسيم اليورانيوم في مئات من اجهزه الطرد
المركزي حينها وكاله الطاقه الذريه لم
تؤكد ولم تنفي تقرير بلومبرج وقالت انها
تجر مناقشات مع ايران بشان نتائج انشطه
التحقق الاخيره على ان تبلغ مجلس محافظي
لوكاله الدوليه بذلك اذا لزم الامر رد
طهران على تقرير جاء على لسان المتحدث
باسم منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه بهروس
كمالوندي الذي قال ان وجود جسيم او جسيمات
مخصبه بنسبه تفوق 60% لا يعني انتاج
بتخصيب اكثر وان وجود هذه الجزيئات في
موقع التخصيب امر شائع اليوم صرح رئيس
منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه محمد سلام
بان المفتشين موجودون في طهران ويقومون
باجراء مفاوضات وعمليات تفتيش لمنع ظهور
حالات او حوادث غامضه جديده
مسؤول الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
موجودون في طهران منذ امس وهم يجرون
محادثات وجولات تفتيشيه وتمحل الغموض الذي
صاحب تقارير احد المفتشين حول نسب التخصيب
ونحن نحافظ على علاقاتنا مع الوكاله
الدوليه في حدود الضمانات الاطراف
الرئيسيه في الاتفاق النووي لم تفي
بالتزاماتها والولايات المتحده لم تتعاون
بهذا الخصوص ولم تسمح ايضا للاخرين
بالتعاون لذلك لن نتسامح مع الضغوط
السياسيه واثاره المشكلات
[موسيقى]
لكن ما الذي تحتاجه ايران لانتاج قنبله
ذريه هذا بالطبع بعد العثور على جزيئات
يونانيوم مخصب بتركيز 84% كما قلنا نسبه
التخصيب المقرره لايران بحسب الاتفاق
النووي لعام 2015 تتراوح بين ثلاثه وخمسه
في المئه في يناير من عام 2021 وصلت ايران
الى نسبه 20% من التخصيب وهي نسبه كافيه
للاستخدامات الطبيه وايضا لاستعمالها
كوقود للغواصات ولحاملات الطائرات النسبه
وصلت الى 60% في ابريل من 2021 في ايران
مؤخرا ارتفعت النسبه الى
84% داخل منشات نوويه ايرانيه لكن عندما
ترتفع نسبه الى ما بين 85% وتسعين في
المئه هذه نسبه تتيح الاستخدام للاغراض
العسكريه لكن لن يقف الامر هنا فلا تزال
هناك رحله يقدرها الخبراء بين عام الى
عامين من اجل الحصول على سلاح نووي هذه
المرحله تشمل تصنيع راس حربي نووي ثم
تحسين نظام الصواريخ الباليستيه وتصميم
صاروخ قادر على حمل هذه الراس